you know my grandma maybe it's because
my grandma's chirping in my ear
and she has been she goes when are you
going to get married when are you going
to have kids you'd be such a good dad
you give you such a good
a do you hear this from your mom and b
do you really
think you want to get married and have
kids or you want to get married have you
thought or do you think
you know what i like being alone and
being in relationships every once in a
while and that's how i
think i am wired uh
as far as my parents expectations
i think uh my parents
understand that their choices and their
schedule
uh was good for them and right for them
uh at their time
when the world was a certain way and
when their choices were
what they were uh my the world around
us you and i right now is different our
industry is
different i'm i'm a little displaced
uh there's a lot of things that are a
little bit different but i think my
parents understand that i am not
in the same world or on the same
schedule
so and and they already have two
spectacular
grandkids that they're really really
pleased with so that took a lot of
pressure on
that's good but do you think like you
ever look in the future and go
you know maybe i'll get married someday
or
uh i don't know why why do i have to get
married why does why you just be with
someone
or or do you feel that kind of pressure
or societal
i don't feel pressured man and as far as
what's gonna happen in the future i mean
i look at my life and i think
i never once imagined my life would be
exactly what it is right now uh this is
the dream
for me i was i was locked up in canadian
winters depressed as a kid going this is
really rotten i wish i could ride my
bike and some sunshine
and i now i live in los angeles i'm i
i pretend for a living i
um we make believe i mean
boil it down it's we get together
and we do really high quality
make-believe i
love my job